[Musique]
bon concert va jouer dans le trafic le
soir comme le matin pour circuler en
ville
il faut s'armer de patience il y as
pie-ix en chantier jusqu'en décembre
2022 donc franchir à peu près 3 km sur
le boulevard pie-ix ça nous a repris
environ une vingtaine de minutes il ya
aussi saint denis est complètement fermé
vers le sud
le doute au delà suggéré pour la rue
saint denis nous mène tout droit vers
une rue barrée c'est larry klein qui est
bloqué exaspéré le conducteur de cette
mini vans par en sens inverse un recul
en jeu savoir comment ça se passe sur
l'île de montréal aujourd'hui
quand elle ne m'aime pas une rue barrée
la signalisation des détours que parfois
porter à confusion
totalement inefficace ça devrait être la
nuit là seulement ça tous les jours
certains enragent d'autres se résigne
ben c'est ce qu'il faut s'attendre après
le manque d'investissement pendant des
années il y en a qui prennent les grands
moyens
je vous dirais qu'on déménage au bureau
je te vends portion on parle de
centre-ville
il n'y a pas que les chantiers et la
signalisation qui dérange vous devrez
aller voir sur papineau
c'est n'importe quoi là ils ont fait ça
en une voie avec des voies de bus et
ferrandi n'importe quoi on a mis une
demi heure pour faire un trajet qui nous
prenait 2 minutes avant avec la nouvelle
voie réservée aux autobus papineau et le
matin congestionné plus que jamais cette
camionnette blanche mettra plus de
quatre minutes pour franchir 40 mètres
mais le bouchon le plus impressionnant
est celui de la rue saint-joseph pour
franchir la distance entre papineau et
saint denis
il faut prévoir près de 35 minutes 35
minutes pour franchir un seuil de 6 km